it's dinnertime here in this rainforest
in the Democratic Republic of Congo this
pearl spotted outlet has captured a
tasty snack a hawk moth while nearby a
tiny primate called a bush baby finds a
praying mantis finger lickin good
okay time for this outlet to tie on the
feedbag but what the heck turns out the
hawk moth is protected by a dense layer
of microscopic scales the force of the
owl at grabbing them off dislodges its
scales
making it one slippery meal to hold on
to what the hawk moth didn't plan for is
the hunger and tenacity of the outlet
bursts of dusty scales are not this is
dinner the bush babies fair isn't so
problematic that's alright the olitz
ceremoniously stuffs the molting moth in
its mouth and takes off
leaving behind an afterglow of moon dust
for the forests other diners